félicitations nous avons atteint les 4
millions d'abonnés ouais nan sans
déconner merci beaucoup et bravo à vous
vous avez participé à atteindre ce
chiffre incroyable aujourd'hui je vais
vous appeler pour vous remercier parce
que les petits messages la part clavier
de type pop périphériques s'énervant je
vous ai donc demandé de l'envoyer par
message privé facebook votre numéro et
puis je vous appelez voilà allez on y va
c'est parti ça je tiens mon cas ce jeu
bien entendu très con ça alors bravo tu
est la grande gagnante
ah oui c'est une blague allez à bientôt
ça va bien ça va très bien que fais tu
t'es tu regardais pas madhalim vidéo ah
bon ça va alors merci c'est très gentil
c'est assure aussi d'ailleurs le ctu à a
va verser à toi bah écoutes je te fais
de gros bisous et puis je te dis à très
bientôt
ciao cette fois on appelle un homme bien
viril
oui oui je sais ta gueule salut théo
je suis triste tu ne m'a pas répondu on
appelle un deuxième homme très viril oui
comment ça va bah ça va très bien tu
étais tu es en train du frère quentin du
tour à oui tu fais du sport quand un os
cassé pas mal cela c'est la veille
capelle disent les défoncer au téléphone
tu fais quoi dans le sport ah ouais mais
sébastien c'est nul ça c'est c'est pour
les gens pour ça non plus j'aime bien le
hamilton voilà chaque fois je rate le
volant mais c'est pas grave tant fait
pour combien de temps ah ouais donc tata
du gros biceps un peu olalala modestie
ou à la modestie s'il te plaît quentin
déjà moi j'ai fait trois ans jim ok bah
voilà bah pourquoi tu dis que j'ai
encore de larges portes à l'appel et
agressent les brèches
ben écoute merci en tout cas de dossiers
de vidéos et puis bravo pour tes 4
millions d'abonnés je me rappelais pas
continuer merci beaucoup content c'est
très aimable
tout le monde dit au revoir à quand un
au revoir quentin
tiens tiens des maps ce canton alors
j'appelle cette personne ce qu'elle a le
même nom que moi au chat je vois aussi
du fake ou pas oui allô est ce que ton
nom de famille c'est vraiment au char à
la france est déçu non non pas minimum
c'est quoi c'est quoi bénard dit tu
faisais quoi là tu as une panne de
réseau à le réseau qui bug fraude
non non je te laisse et lan wan chai que
tu as un gros fdp d'habitude la france
ben blague
ah ouais mais cyprien il t'appelle après
aussi un dans une blague au bas merci
c'est très gentille madame lochard ab
nardi par donc passer une bonne soirée
merci beaucoup en tout cas sa lutte et
où est ce que tu es vieri louis à
j'aimerais bien que tu moquer tu me
dises non quoi pour je me sente un peu
mieux j'étais en train de lancer une
partie sur toi et tu regardais pas ma
dernière vidéo j'ai regardé derrière
avec douche savon des sûretés au jeu
séparément sont jetés aux lions comme ça
au oui c'est bon c'est bon t'es où tu ne
vois pas et à très bientôt dans une
nouvelle
allez à bientôt théo tient très adapté
au style à votre iphone tu fais un petit
commentaire à la con de bouffe le
dernier rotin si je puis me perdre
allô oui monsieur quentin comment allez
vous je m'attendais à ce qu'un mec viril
réponse bizarre c'est une voix tout
aiguë quoi elle fuit chaque quart avant
sont d'avis comme ça quand même
il est timide il est un peu maigrichon
il est grincheux aussi haut
qu'est-ce que vous étiez en train de
faire au moment je vous appelez ne
mentez pas 16 alerte
bah ouais mais il va pas trop quoi
répondre
bah communique avec les chats à travers
les murs vasily t'écoute web merci
beaucoup et puis a bien fait les enfants
bijoux allait retourner copuler latorre
de petits commentaires villa jacques
walter est comme ça ils étaient très
mignons comme 12 en fait c'est trop
mignon
ce oui hello i sava oulata loi qui
tremblote héloïse comment tu vas
qu'est-ce que tu étais en train de faire
là quand je t'ai appelé à quelle belle
occupation et lewis et louisa torsion as
tu vu la dernière vidéo berry bon c'est
bien est ce que ton nom de famille c'est
au char à toi aussi je suis déçu quand
j'aurai raccroché tu arrêteras de me
taper 1
attention à louisa bravo pour tes 4
millions d'abonnés écoute puis à bientôt
dans une prochaine
ouais tiens aux gros bisous à fils
excellente on appelle monsieur pouilles
comment ça va monsieur pouilles va ça va
très bien écouter oiseaux pouilles bari
va très bien ah oui monsieur pouilles
oui qu'est-ce que tu étais en train de
faire quand je t'ai appelé monsieur oui
est ce que monsieur pouces se serait
fait dépouiller bike et etc etc etc etc
etc étiez-vous en train de faire ben tu
m'a quand même laissé 20 secondes
seulement moi j'avais peur alors tu
étais en train de faire une aussi à ce
que je t'ai appelé et alors est ce
qu'elles étaient bonnes la sieste à
comme une merde d'accord avec la couette
ou pas sur toi aller tester chez nous ah
ben c'est bien monsieur gautier ça ça
veut dire que quand tu as trahi et toi
d'énergie tu es prêt à réviser le bac
kan
eh ben tu dois l'être quand même non666
pas monsieur pouilles
bah écoute a fait faire plaisir d'être
par les messieurs poule
bat encore bravo pour tes 4 millions
d'abonnés et puis à bientôt dans une
prochaine vidéo à toi alors on va
appeler la championne du monde du cloud
elle m'a envoyé son numéro sans déconner
cette fois par minute depuis le début de
cette vidéo
alors comment ça en me flou de sur
facebook mais tu vas payer un pv
vraiment les weppes hutin away ces
personnes problème comment tu vas et ben
moi aussi mais merci de me demander
vraiment ça me fait très très plaisir
je te souhaite une très bonne soirée
voilà donc tu recevras ton amant de sous
48 heures au quai sont longues à bab tu
vas y tu crois que tu vas l'avoir sous
le nez j'te le dis gros bisous lui si
elle paie ton âme homme va c'est parti
cette fois on appelle un couple ces
crises et sa copine
comment ça va j'ai un sanglier au
téléphone on est vraiment une ferme dans
une affaire où il ya des cochons avoue
jean quéré un peu bon bah je vais vous
laisser tranquille monsieur le sanglier
wind et m'agresser pas à bientôt
bon bah crise désolé mais je t'appelle
et on lui a volé son téléphone tu veux
rencontrer les filles haute de ta région
appelle le nain appels facturés 2000
euros la minute en france métropolitaine
oui bonjour j'aimerais rencontrer les
filles haute de ma région bonjour où
puis je rencontrais l'une de ces femmes
d'accord et de se faire des amis c'est
ça c'est une fausse annonce que tu m'as
fait mais non mais c'est quand même une
grosse l'annoncé par contre les 12000
euros ça c'est pas faux c'est vous savez
devrait vraiment être débité mais voilà
la belle maman mais elle prend quand
même de l'argent dans la foulée c'est
bon bah écoute bravo pour tes 4 millions
d'abonnés et bien à la haye la grande
virée pour danser super bien bon gros
bisous lucas très bientôt ouais ça lui
il aura tient elle était hyper doué
incroyable ça donnerait une grande
actrice hollywoodienne by jour je te
donne mon numéro ps ne dit pas ma meuf
elle sera pas content tu attends je vais
l'appeler je lui demandais c'est géré
lien elle va leur gueule et seront va
briser un couple uni berckois géniaux et
loyaux et a trouvé pour le moment
jamais plus jamais voilà comment ça va
valentin ça va et toi
ah ouais et valentin tu as un peu de
barbe j'ai pu voir sur ta photo oui
c'est quoi ton secret est ce que tu peux
nous dire tous les jours et quand on en
a vraiment très peu comment on fait pour
en avoir plus on va verser beaucoup
valentin à très bientôt pompidou salut
luca j'avais surtout car tu passais des
coûts de bigot 12h cette expression bah
oui c'est moi ça vas y toi fort bien
j'ai vu sur ce que tu nous passer des
coups de canon c'est quoi cette
expression coup de bigot ça se dit d'où
s'était tu viens d'où la courage mon
gars ah ouais tu prévu le moigne qui tue
à dire ah ouais ah ah ah mais attends
excuse moi mais excuse moi tellement
offensés je vais mourir s'te plaît quand
je vois des vidéos je te jure nixon plus
vache pompe le dire tu vois ah bah merci
c'est gentil
bah moi quand je vois les tiennent aussi
je kiffe grave bah ouais sont trop bien
tu fais pas des vidéos non pourquoi
ah ok mais c'est une blague à la base et
tout mais dans le limousin et
comprennent pas les blagues que je fais
et bah ouais ben c'est grâce à moi quand
on est là donc tu te calmes direct sur
des soins poste-clé ouais bah sur ta
prochaine vidéo demain 8 heures voilà tu
es mon esclave tout à fait ok mais
continue surtout un je voulais arrêter
bah tu sais quoi je voulais raccrocher
arrêté en fait wagon vie je n'en garde
pas passé une super bonne soirée je te
parie mon ami de tous à bientôt
merci beaucoup thiam on vient on appelle
benjamin qui est le dernier et commença
à benjamin ben ça va du nord allait
jouer samedi tapas pavé comme un gros
porc vous avez tous fait ça vous êtes
tous des chenapans vous êtes des petits
filous moi je bon bah tu me sens pas
mais en plus tu me raccroche à la gueule
benjamin c'est comme ça que ça se passe
chez toi et est ce que tu fais du sport
benjamin aller comme moi est ce que
quand même ton tour de bras à augmenter
un peu absolument pas dice qui voit en
rêve la diminuer est-ce que voir mais le
côté partie de la salle qui musclent
était encore trop longue c'est les corps
de la schl on peut rien y faire a tenté
entend assurer que j'ai encore de lâches
comme toi là gros bisous mon gars merci
pour tout on se croise bientôt grave
poussée de la fontaine oublie pas
problème et ben voilà les gens se dire
français vidéo spéciale quatre pylônes
j'espère que ça vous a plu c'est
toujours un plaisir de vous parler comme
ça c'est beaucoup d'émotions vraiment
vous vous êtes trop mignon et bat encore
remercier encore bravo pour vos capitons
d'abonnés c'est incroyable je suis là
depuis vos vins à beaune et donc j'adore
cette blague laissez moi laissez moi un
peu grâce à des codes et merci beaucoup
c'est super cool et puis bon on va
continuer comme ça pour encore longtemps
j'espère et puis je vous dis à bientôt
dans une prochaine vidéo vous saviez la
suite n'est ce pas portez vous bien jo
tout le monde pis